I have been experimenting with the RIFE machine for parasites and I ran several programs to be the first three and I developed a kind of a stomachache that seems to be lingering.
Okay, so the truth is is everybody's got parasites.
So should people be running parasite programs? Absolutely.
So can you hurt yourself running parasite programs?
Maybe Dr. Kelly would think differently but I don't think so.
Your killing parasites is a good thing.
The only thing that I'd be careful of if you have Lyme disease or something you don't want to do a whole lot of kill too fast.
If you're dealing with, if you got cancer and you want to start running some parasite programs and such, a good set to start with is that is in the alphabetical file is the clean me up program.
And I think there's five of those. So clean me up, clean me up to three, four, five or six of them or something.
That'd be a good set to start with. If you suspect specific parasites, then you could go to those specific parasites.
If you suspect fluks around worms or something, certainly go to those.
If you got a gut ache, you got a stomach ache from the parasites. The only thing I would say is, you know, how often are you having a ball moment, maybe drink more water.
There's some, if you're like feeling like you're trying to do some more with your life, because you're doing well with your cancer, then I would say you could add an anti parasitic nutritional protocol like one kind of general one that we have on our website is.
A product called proverba fuge and that one has a lot of parasitic anti parasitic nutrition in there. You could take a couple of those a day and maybe cycle that on and off like Paul said, maybe do it just every weekend, you take three a day just on the weekend and you run the parasite programs. It's going to clean you out.
You're always exposed to parasites. So even if you it's the same thing as with toxins in your body, you're never going to be parasite free per se because you're always exposed to them.
And even if you do a stool sample and we measure and you have no parasite activity, you still have parasites.
So there, so it's running that on a regular basis is a good idea. There are some products that are very anti cancer products like burmarine that are also very good to help kill parasites, and especially bacteria in your gut.
So yeah, if you have a stomach ache just make sure you're having a bowel with every day, they make sure you drink some more water, maybe take some anti parasite nutrition and I wouldn't I wouldn't stop doing it and quite possibly the it's just coincidental.